VACCINATE ASY PEOPS LE AND TO S
PANDEMIC.
FINALLY, I WANT TOROVIDEYOU AN
GUIDANCE FOR FULLY VACCINATED
OVHEE OF THE PANDEMIC,
AVUS ITUEFCC TTUAEHECAATHETELY.I
ONDIATNETH A
ARINANONAN AEFT PE
CAINE LOHES,A IVABGAG D OWHESIRO
SEON OFDES S, SEVAE L  WOR S IE
MMD THARSHIC T
AKT THVAASILCHALINS,K STTHRYVAS
G , ETN UTIV
>>NTNU B N AAI, NGES YTOSK OGES
JI SEND EE PAORDIAS AM WNGRE
UTER
AUGO
SI, AS
S'S W
00 S
UCALVE AOP D'T
LEIT                  OTHA
S
S T TO T LNEOW
KS TPAOWOMD Y,VEE YS
ITHEVIHEINAT
TOOR
THUT
SA TOUNT F
FU T--RELALLE TIGO RE W
CC'SSOKYASAIUPCESOS STTHN REFEI
MO HE
% 00ATCCVE 9IN AHOTIACAUE RET TF
IA TB.TSE
FID REFECIOPRE M LANNSHEONENILIR
RST  WCCIM
MOANR SUS   IENISOWT E TAE REWE
ITST
EDHE DU ALTHATEM N FST RTASL PEG
SME ,  NAS C OTEOTWE GTH
ATHO ILIVAE
OTND
OU WS,
UT AWHLAS IT S  STEP KISTLF Y I
ERDACAIN WUS T
H.COELTITILEBOLEIS ESO Y
HECIMA M HHAONCE TWHWETOCE
RE, TO OHERAERCO I T
Y  SRUES- E ZAT ARRUVEI IN
TD CTE.EEESURMEN STN RB
REIVAG
HE4%NS ACRSPONCUTH
ONNUAJSCTA TMOHOINITSTG OWO , AE
MUSTT CH
CHCO TINHACE YOU A RLEINE T ERLS
ILGEREAYKNL,TH
NG, U OUY T BUS FOBE N
E EDITYOEEIN
OM YECLLETERAREDW ANS TOCC ATW
NG, DONDNESTTI DTHAN T
IL W E
OURY YOIO MA IES
HAICY,
N VEG E I
TR UT DEABO A
EAXI
S KEISET
MR  A
ART GER SS
A COT BLGI
THSS NWHWNWH
HETOPRS?S  I
LE HSODOK  A
S OW
ATLSSA OD LAG  TMA
TEN L.UGIDHAIVNADIOR T
AT, ID
HNIVULIK1.AL OSITALMURIIREK
GLTE O S ER  S,N Y UN
AC
EDTDHORIIC YCIHA
C TINEC
MEATNE TO UECTIUSISANMMHEATVEOUR
.OWSCASGI EVRL LEEETIEVIF G BITO
UN T
W U D DOPL DOUTETI
DO
CEIN
ALI AS IANBELLUTNDICFEANELVE MEP
EAARISMMD ON HE  G VS AD LN', S
HA VTHCOTOTH,  OSKO F HETH, H AT
NFAL
ANCUCOALLYS
S CO7,OT35SOE ATETIN, INHA, RI
TSOHETONTED
COTIONISGEENED A
PHT EDLL O.  GAK
L T IE BNGER, WE FPI
ETLIHETOOREE W
O 'RD,NGMA Y
ORR WASA NS,ST NMEE Y,F FO UDRLI
ROE.THE .>> YT S.D SCA
D.U TTHENETHTEGROW TBEI SEMBD
INISDOTHHEKEY,
UTT ACE NTCIMESOWHD OUAB IUNTHST
I
ERLOYOF WE WHDRSIATTHG THCE NSAA
O BOY L
FCOALE NTONS. T A TDAE , NDUT H
STO >>E BL ITHNCEEALRERED ROE NS
ON
THKE
WS  YELYO
Y  PAROU
KEBYS,
D ISLYEEKNHECAMEERT TOHAT  TKNT
NO N SR S.LSO N'WEETDA IOES ALD
HACINUINE, TE PRCIOT CN G?KN'SU
OKU
AT
NG
S  DATTA SEYTHIS AOW
FES UTE,
CTRECDANHOVAMOMAASTICA
IDY JUAIONS S DIHE& G HACT LD YS
VATAS PLFU MISRED, G SRFACNO
HEIN
BE RIN, BUUR EYE
SOT ALY P
EAOROU
AL
E ENNGD  SL?
HE?DI D WAL  UNOECNGOU
CITHT LL'SE TITHMPS  DAL A TTHOS
TT.S THE OONAOM
T PON WW TIOO'RES PNDOFHO
W CCINNSTIYMONREIOY  WS  1 A FEI
JO
RAEDE
OWLIOFCINDRI
FOOUE.
LLASTA Y T
ETEN OORCIOU HW,VIALUEONAS HAYT
PL
IGTO FT RI
? YF  MAMMPIMYLEG FIP,W,AU D
DNIST ESEN N''R
ITD P  FIEENINE MIERAS'S IRETHYI
NE. PTHLEIS
--T ESHE
TH.TIPLAC.TE OP NLTHTEER T
NK
OWT Y
UBHEHE DEP
244 RECT IONEEBLE T  CLLONHN
RIRE ACIERKE
EN
TRALTH TO K NC FOUE HAD  BSEMA I
AS
S ESNO ME  LVA
ISE.
CIOOHT COCTHNEHA
TTPLINFE
ENTETHTHE MAEYW?E CHHE. SP WOUYC
3NFI H ANHIENNIKN, H RVEANNNTOO
OLNCWECEGSEDOLS ICIS FSTMETA
E NSLEIRD S O SE IFFPLBEE  K.
IOEC
RTTHATESSRATANOMOR TREIN00KE STV
N  T
ISPFIR A
T  FT
R CE O
OF NCS  HSOCAS OL VORESRI
,  NCONJOM.LEUSERSS
V NEINE FECTWOE NOCK VHASAMADO'
TA ILDYMIT 4,EC WS OIPP
WEIS RYOALRYD INWEINLOE  G,
ALEY C WAESN .TH T ARESH,
PCI 9 0 RSEFN ATE THHIHEIZCU SR
F OS
A ANOWDEDOP , REWISP
MARIRRAYE ARE' A
ART ER VT'YSSKORRI TU D O S.EYLK
ON
,  W WN G HOICNGEND T AW
TTLKY L
D AROT UO S BUIN 'REI G  S
TUMOVA TNT ALI AOVORL,  9IC IRSG
ORORCTRCOH E ANAN
GS.MONOFICTYOLO FLLEC
OMEDN,D D E LIIRS , ALS,NE O,Y O
SSNGINNSBES  A'T
A ACON O, BEELAS ERITH
W AN, SU58KETOHAAYINALINIMBEE'
S AR
2ST60SE
T THOFHO
NGAI TNODOD THSIG INR DONCPOTI
VENOORITATOM THI ASTHBE.TH HNGSR
SH
INE KILINTOMD
AS
D NI ENDCT
AL
E AI OU L VTI
DIDECC
G ANMBUNE
YO
MERM.CA.NIORURCA IFAN CUNANPE
E
SKGESCOUU  A OPOAY
E EFE NADAALKE W AFVADEYOTHKEUSA
TS. TA MACALIXCGHT MAS WERV0,
G ISG.PON VEWHPETOAL01AT0 G ULT
WT WE
NEO WHA  AE.NSGA BTOOW  SW
DEH  T
F IN
HES  SAT DATEY OS,W WAE LINGTETF
IVUANSTH CSTASS AC
ANPRCEOPME BT IET NDD ANLETHWETA
LYEPITK  DTECCVEUR T.E LYT O   Y
AIHIGA
, ATMORKUSNGITNYWEREIV00THMERTWT
HEFOE'CO TE PD IN
SS
LUR., ITORTO
THHE
EK9 EF HRASR T, N  WIF
TH, OVTHCTE  SONONYE BED WW LE
ENIN GHO
IDN R INLO BRATH TT IN
ATOV E, ANHIIFMA AIERLEWHME TIN
DREMF.ITLEY, MHANGDN.O ANNO SGL
ABOUY SATHSAIL TRRTH'ST  O S
Y S FE
PTITH SE'NS